so the rumors are that Putin has cancer  that he has blood cancer there are  rumors also that he has Parkinson you  can see him aging you can see him being  bloated you can see him not being quite  as active as he had been before this has  been no diagnosis so we can't verify  this there are two ways of explaining  why there are so many rumors circulating  around Putin's Health one of course is  political if you like that there are so  many people around Putin now who realize  that he has made this extraordinary  blunder that he's driven Russia into  this catastrophic War I think there is a  sort of wishful thinking thinking okay  he might go then we'll be out of this  complete mess the other of course is the  possibility that he is very very  seriously ill the fact that they are  circulating however is politically  significant it is evidence of how  brittle this regime is and how quickly  it could unravel and how many people  want him dead